what's going on everybody welcome to
part two of our data visualization with
Python a matplotlib tutorial series in
this tutorial we're going to be talking
about legends titles and labels within
matplotlib so graft sometimes can be
relatively self-explanatory especially
if they're input into some sort of
context but generally it's a good idea
to have a title and labels in your x and
y-axes and then also a legend can also
be really helpful especially if you're
plotting multiple you know series of
data so with that let's go ahead and hop
right in so first of all when you're
graphing in matplotlib chances are
you're not going to actually have any
like hard-coded variables otherwise you
probably wouldn't be using a programming
language you would just I don't know
plug it into Excel or something like
that so at the end of the day usually
what happens is you have X and X as a
list and Y and y it will be a Python
list too and then you'll have some
function that populates x and y but for
now I mean we can just we can just take
our old values here cut and paste and
we'll just say x and y and we'll just
pretend that this was a function it's
not but we'll pretend that for now so
first of all what we want to do is we
can add titles and labels and the way
that we're going to do that is we just
do it before we call the dot show and so
after the plot we can come down here and
we can say PLT dot and then we can say X
label and this will be for that you know
bottom axes the x-axis and we can just
call this the plot number and then the
PLT dot y label and we call this the
important var that's what it is and and
that should be it the next thing we can
do is we can also add a title so we can
say PLT title and in here we can say we
call this an interesting graph and what
you can do in a title first let's I
guess we'll bring this one up and then
I'll show you guys one more thing but so
let's go ahead and save and run that
rope
quick and here we see we've got this
interesting graph title we've got the X
ax well the x axis down here and the y
axis over here and also you can take
note that the y axis is automatically
like flipped a little bit there so it
goes up and down vertically rather than
horizontally so this is just
automatically done for you and it's
mostly just a safe space but anyways you
can see we've got this title it's a
little larger than these numbers down
here and all that and later on we'll
talk all about customization like
everything in matplotlib is customizable
so we can also change the font sizes and
all everything basically here so anyway
so we have that now like what if like a
lot of people have like subtitles there
is a way to do subtitles in matplotlib
but a lot of times this is good enough
where you'll have interesting graph and
then you use a newline character so
that's a backslash n so that backslash
is right above your Enter key
so backslash n um check it check it out
make sure you don't add a space there so
we had a space there it'll add that
space on the new line like I'll start
with a space and that's not what you
want so we could do something like that
we'll save and run that and sure enough
there you go interesting graph check it
out cool and all that so we'll go ahead
and close out of this and now the only
other thing I want to cover is legends
so the reason why you would have a
legend is maybe if you had two two lines
so let's go ahead and add an X two and a
y two and let's just give them we'll do
one two and three again but then the Y 2
will be let's just make all these
numbers over 10 so let's do 10 14 12 so
now what we can do is we can go PLT plot
and then x - y - okay and to do a
legends basically you can all you have
to do is just invoke the legend so you
can just do PLT legend and now we have
an alleged element here but we have no
nothing to put in the legend so there's
no way format plot
to just know what our lines are so we
use a keyword argument in this pie plot
plot and that is going to be label and
so we say label equals and then the
string of what we want so we would call
this the you know first line and then we
would call this second one here we would
say label equals and then we'll just say
this is the second line so that's that
now all we need to do is save and run
that and there you go now you've got
your two lines here's a line up here and
here's a line down here now this is just
a really simple and quick you know intro
kind of few videos here so as you can
see we're we've got this line that's
running through our legend that's
obviously not what you want happening so
later on we'll be talking about how to
customize the legend so that does not
happen but for now this is good enough
just to show the legends exist so that's
it for now we've got the labels now and
legends and basically a lot of the
required elements to make your graph a
little more easy to understand if you
have any questions or comments about
this please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching things for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time